good evening everybody
i'm david atten and i chair this
scrutiny committee can i
welcome all members uh and all officers
to this meeting
and welcome all those that are
um viewing the live stream
and i'll just mention the live stream uh
it can be viewed at a later date on
youtube
as well as obviously being stream live
now
and members please can you
mute your mic when not speaking and if
you wish to speak
please ask in the chat room so if you
could
just log into the chat room
uh that that that will be helpful
um the first item on the agenda is
attendance and i've had
apologies from council win stanley and
councillor shaw
is there any other apologies
no uh item two is declarations of
interest
if any members got a declaration of
interest in any items on the agenda
can you please shout out now
okay item three is questions
from the public now i've received
um a question from mr stevenson
who is a resident of pickford court
which is one of the high-rise flats in
old
trafford and we have circulated
mr stephens question and i think
when you add it up there are 16
questions which are directed to both
trafford housing trust and the council
and clearly we we will need to ask uh
trafford housing trust to answer some of
those questions
and the council will answer those that
are
directed to the council they're all
valid questions that need to be answered
um and what i'm suggesting tonight
because of the
the number of questions and the
complexity of the questions
what we'll need to do is to gather
the answers to those questions
and report back to the committee
and relay those uh answers
to mr stevenson i think he has
he has been contacted and i think he is
content
with that and i intend to
therefore have an agenda item on the
next
scrutiny committee meeting uh to
obviously discuss
those uh answers to those questions
is everybody happy with that
yeah sure
it can i mean sure quite some time since
um
the scrutiny work at the acm club
industry
sort of first came to committee um
and obviously we've already heard from
cht um
i think that the resident is a i can't
remember his name i'm sorry apologetic
stevenson yeah mr stevenson's raised
questions that i think
committee members themselves asked at
the time and i think
a few of us perhaps had some
reservations about some of the responses
particularly around the
advice the um tht said they'd received
from
gm frs um i'm just wondering
um whether or not you've had direct
contact with mr stevenson or
whether that would be the opportunity
for us to speak with him as committee
members because i think
it's interesting to hear his perspective
i didn't know anything about
the the flat fires that he referred to
in the questions and i just think
um given the the uh efforts he's gone to
to try and
involve the committee i i'd welcome if
he's comfortable with it having perhaps
just an
informal conversation or a formal
conversation whatever whatever you
prefer
to to hear about well to understand more
about his perspective as a resident i
suppose
yeah i i totally agree with with your
comments and um i i think that's enough
in the question to do that uh to to
to warren digging into uh the points
that he's made and we have raised
some of those points ourselves uh and
obviously we with the pandemic it has
been very difficult
this is our first meeting back as a kind
of ordinary
uh committee scrutiny committee uh
previously over the last
10 months we've had a pandemic scrutiny
committee so it has been
difficult in terms of that communication
but i think
[Music]
it's quite timely really that we've
received this
um this email uh with with a list of
questions
uh and what what what i can do is either
talk to him personally or
ask him if he would be prepared to come
to
the next meeting obviously we we can
invite tht
as well um
you know try and get the answers to uh
many of the questions that have been
raised
i think we we do have an item obviously
tonight on uh
item seven which is a replacement of the
acm cladding work
on on the high-rise
you know accommodation and um
we we we will come to that uh
when when we get to item seven uh it is
a you know a short
email that we've been sent and i thought
it was
only right to share that with all the
members and
and keep this in our mind because this
leads to the
massive issue for the residents who live
in these
high rise class and we've seen it
nationally the problems that are
existing at this moment in time and i
think we need to be
um you know really scrutinize
scrutinizing some of the um serious
issues that
we know exist so with that
can we now move on to uh
item four which is a minutes uh from the
11th of march
2020. we agree those are the
true record you know it's a long time
ago but and that's when we last actually
meant to
met as a um as the
previous committee was
okay if everybody's happy with that
we'll move on to
item five um and this is
uh the active transport uh we asked for
uh some kind of uh report and
presentation
i think we've we've received some
written presentation
and i think we've got with us tonight
richard rowe who is a director
of place and we've got chris morris who
i'm not quite sure of you titled chris
and i think you you will probably be
um doing the presentation and we have
counselor steve
said i don't know steve if you wanted
just to say a few words of introduction
thank you chair just uh very briefly uh
we have one agenda yes as you
might remember uh i attended the
committee some
a while ago now and we gave uh i gave a
verbal update
at that point and actually where things
look to having committee members
did us to be kept updated where things
are up to
but also they think they wanted more
specific information which hopefully
the the slideshow which uh you'll be
seeing shortly i think was sent out to
members earlier
we'll be able to actually give a lot
more detail uh
obviously many of you will know where
richard so you all know richard and i
don't know how many
uh know chris morris but chris morris is
of course our
our director of uh highways transport
and and the environment
i'll be handing over to chris will be
taking us through the slide showing the
second
obviously pleased to give his nights
been very turbulent here
uh particularly especially in terms of
the active
travel fund was it set out in first
place it set out originally
as emergency active travel fund and then
as the government uh
went through the next phases of it it
lost the emergency bit and as he
looked onto more schemes that they might
be able to make not just sort of very
short-term tempted ones but the ones
that were sort of that you'll see
some work on tonight as well as the
temporary ones you see ones that are
looking to make more sort of
semi-tournament
and the way we've actually been trying
to actually put those forward and engage
with communities over that
so with that chair thank you for the
introduction and i'll actually hand over
this christmas part of course i'll
i'll happily contribute to any points i
can as we go through the presentation
but obviously uh
i'll let chris take us through that so
thank you i'll just
mute myself okay thanks very much
councillor i've said uh chris it's so
over to you
and thank you very much for coming along
tonight
that's a pleasure chair um i'm gonna try
and share this
onto it which may or may not work
but i will give it a go
[Music]
it's not quite it's not quite working at
the moment
[Music]
my computer's not letting me advise
there anybody else who could can
actually share these slides onto that
richard for instance i've got the slides
uh
available so i can put them up for you
have you thank you very much for that i
really appreciate it
[Music]
okay can everybody see that
wonderful right um
well thank you yes i'm chris morris i'm
director of highways um
this this year through the through the
pandemic has been
uh fairly challenging because obviously
the government challenged
every local authority to uh to try and
uh and push forward um proposals and
schemes which would
which would actually make people cycle
and
walk more safely around their areas
um we've i think in traffic we've been
always been a
supporter of uh supporters of the active
travel schemes the uh projects such as
talbot road
um which has gone in the bridgewater
canal and of course the mayor's
challenge fund schemes which we've
uh which we've been quite successful in
in um
in securing funding for like the the uh
the erston
active neighborhood and uh and certain
smaller schemes along tolbert road
to uh to actually encourage people to uh
to cycle more
um as councillor outside said the uh the
um emergency active uh travel fund um
was brought in to uh to re to require
uh councils from central government to
do uh
um quick um
uh establish establish kind of temporary
routes
for the uh for people to uh to encourage
uh encourage your cycling
uh cycling uh as an alternative member
uh method of transport during the uh
first lockdown
and the requirements for that were that
they were to be putting in
putting quickly very quickly at times um
with certain constraints on what the
money could be used for it can be used
for existing projects it can be used for
um for things like um
surfacing and so on and so forth and uh
recognizing that
there were some there was a limited time
for consultation
and we did accept that with that comes
an element of trial and error
and within that there there's a need to
to actually react quickly
if we have if we if we had to review and
actually amend the
amend the schemes fairly dynamically
which i think we should
sorry kind of nestle when they get
close um so askgaryvee said the eatf the
the emergency active travel travel
scheme uh was the one that started
during lockdown number one
uh that was followed by the active
travel fund
in the in terms of transit trans2 which
was supporting the creation of longer
term projects so it's a bit
um it's the uh the difference between
putting
the uh the starting uh the starting
proposals quickly in
in place and then moving on to things
which may be semi-permanent
or per or permanent in terms of terms of
cycling infrastructure
to give you to give you a kind of a view
of what some of the uh some of the
constraints
around it the uh tranche one schemes
were
were due to be started within four weeks
of
the confirmation of the funding uh which
is on the 23rd of july 2020
and delivered by the 18th of september
now
realistically that's a very very steep
time scale to do any level of
infrastructure uh
intervention on the on the highway um
and i think dft actually realized that
because the uh that had been extended a
number of times out
to uh to first the 30th of september and
then to do within a three month period
with it with the threat that if uh that
if we um if we did not
kind of do the uh and uh do the schemes
within that time that there could be a
clawback of the money that was uh that
was available
and the toronto proposals that we've
done
we've uh all of the all of them that
have been put in place and i'll go
through a list in a second
they've been instead installed on an
experimental basis so uh so we monitor
them
with uh with um our own staff with
amy staff with uh part of the one trap
at trafford fame um
uh one traffic framework and also we
have uh we have elements of help from
tfgm
in terms of uh in terms of figures and
usage for cycling
cyclists and pedestrians etc in
areas when asked for and so we try
and monitor all of the all of the the
feedback from
people because this has become quite a
uh quite a hot topic i think over the
last uh
of the last um 12 months and uh and
there's a lot of feedback around social
feed and social media
and correspondence into into all this
including the world members
i think what it has to be said is that
uh is that with with these
travel schemes they have certainly been
divisive the uh there is a
there is no scheme i think that we've
put in bar
probably one which uh which has got
anywhere near 100 percent
of people uh people uh wanting to uh
wanted to
to do them or not do them it's always
been a case it
been a case of trying to find find
almost the middle ground to work to work
with these
so we're gonna have the next slide
so how do we go about identifying the uh
identifying the sites we put um we put a
website
uh together we use the website which is
called commonplace
and uh it first been used under uh safe
street save lives
um but what uh what it could uh what it
could allow people to do was to log on
to it
and to uh hunter basically suggests uh
ideas and areas
uh or ideas in areas uh around the
borough
that uh that people could um uh people
could could look at if
it was a concern around an accident
black spot a an idea around
around making something a little bit
better it gave it gave a little bit of
carp launch to uh to people to
to get their views uh we took that data
and we put a uh we we filtered it
and looked and looked at the
possibilities around it where we had
clusters
from uh from various people uh showing
that there was there was quite a bit of
interest in there
and fourteen locations were considered
were considered and we
we started to look at how we how we
could deal with these through through a
quick consultation consultation um
uh process eight of them
didn't didn't require didn't uh get to
the uh get to the community
support and we discarded but the rest we
we looked forward to uh to kind of move
into tranche one
of the next slide
so in terms of the travel schemes that
went forward um modal filters
uh along for park um the a56 um
pop-up cycle lanes which were taken as a
decision prior to uh prior to this
to uh to make use of the fact that the
a56 was not busy
uh during the uh during the lockdown one
and actually encourage people to
uh uh to cycle on that main arterial
route into manchester
edge lane stratfor stratford which was
uh was an addendum to the a56
while stock road in terms of some
bollards on the on those cycle tracks on
either side of the either side of the
road
mobile road model filter and and old
feel length model filter
um start from the top long for park um
in terms of the uh consultation around
it um was um
we we decided that uh during the during
the consultation this
the majority of people wanted something
in longford park
um the minority didn't want anything
and some of the and in terms of the
majority
a goodly percentage went for the
solution that we we've chosen a few with
a few tweaks
either side this um at this at this
moment in time
is still a very hot topic between the
residents of the uh of the area around
longford park and at the moment we've um
we've we've just taken a decision to uh
uh
through through the executive member to
uh to keep that on
for six months and then do a thorough
consultation
consultation to see whether we take it
off or we don't because
within that it is so close in terms of
in terms of what people whether people
want it to happen
or don't want it to happen what it
consists of is
planters being put into into three roads
around the
around the longford park area that
allows for people to uh uh people to
cycle and walk in uh in um
peace and quiet without uh without
through without uh through traffic in
what is known as what is quite a quite a
serious rat run area
and uh cutting the cutting the light
cutting the lights at
on edge lane the a56
um the tranche one was to uh was was to
basically we we have done a temporary
job on the on the a56 i think as anybody
who's driven down there will see the
cones
i think what we want to do now is within
within this tranche one is to change
those
those cones to something which is more
maintainable which is
which is basically basically ones and
also
and also return an element of an element
of road space
um to uh to its existing existing part
where we have bottlenecks
uh but to um but to make sure basically
that
that it was or we could keep it in in
its uh
in its uh current guys butter but um a
little bit
a little bit more professional rather
than the currents
edge lane is edgeline is a continuation
of that
on lostop road uh this is another one
that's uh
proved very designed very divisive it's
two uh it's two cycle lanes on either
side of the uh either side of lostop
road
uh the south uh the south side has a uh
has a tro
on it and has the uh has um some signage
the north side didn't
um there is indication that both our
actual cycle lanes
and there was um and and the
funding that we had enables enabled us
to put some clear ballads down the
uh down each each cycle way to uh to
make sure that people didn't park
within those uh within those areas i
think the problem being on the north
side
is that uh people got used to the fact
that the south side was the
was the key um was the key cycle route
that was
that was uh that was signed
and and i think the the residents were
not happy with the position of some of
the bollards and uh and
in effect what we've what we've done
there is we've taken that on board we
said we'd be uh
we said we'd be agile with it um and
uh and what we've what we have done we
moved around some of the bolos prior to
christmas
and then after that after christmas
looking at the north side with the
with the weight of weighted people's
people's displeasure on that side
we've we've taken the uh we've taken the
bollards out
mobile road um fell and a little
uh is uh is basically something that we
will still look at with network rail but
actually
actually didn't it didn't come off and
the oldfield lane
of elaine actually has been our success
story that i think people uh people
really uh
really liked it was uh it's uh down to
was done in massey and
and it works um for the uh for um
for making it making it into a into a
really um
a really good cycle way down into uh
down into the countryside so
it's been well received by the community
um but in itself
it wasn't correct first time because of
the speed that we were doing it we were
doing things that
that we we had to make some some
adjustments to the planters and just
an adjustments to the signage to make it
into the position that it's in at the
moment
another next one please
okay in terms of the consultation it's
been been across a little uh a little
bit of this already
um but um but for long for part two we
actually did three separate
consultations because it was very close
on either on
on all um on all angles and uh mostly it
appeared to be third third third third
third being uh being
uh don't want anything a third wanting
uh wanting
a uh the the solution that we we put and
a third
and a third wanting a different solution
of any particular type
so hence the decision that we came to
that i went through just a few minutes
ago
um in terms of uh in terms of the the
a56
um the semi-permanent uh measures on
measures on that we
were we're looking at um we're looking
at
well we we did a consultation regards
the safe street save live
lives website but realistically we're
looking at we're looking at just firming
up those
firming up those cones in three phases
southbound edge lane to m60
northbound m62 edge lane and uh and then
northbound edge lane to talbot road
now the next line please
edge lane uh was it the uh the tranche
one bit uh
is the removal of the existing temporary
bollards and replacing the same easier
with the semi-permanent ones again uh
i'm freeing up an element the footway
because people are actually moving the
cones so uh so we have lost a fair few a
fair few guns over the
over the period of time uh people do
move them around
and we've had uh and we've had we have
a quite a maintenance task actually to
go back and back and do them and making
the wall
putting the ones in for the a56 and the
edge lane
actually we'll save we'll save money in
the long term
um we of the of the ones that i
mentioned that didn't go ahead
we took a lot of consultations around
nash overstreet uh bradfield road
uh ghost avenue area lost road
canterbury area
uh and oxford road peter street area and
with the exception of the
the last one um most of those have been
have been put onto
uh onto onto the back burner really
because the the residents did not
uh go for the uh go for the solutions
that were that were raised uh
or had objections with us doing any kind
of cycling uh cycling bit
uh cycling or walking but oxford road
and peter street
we push back into charge two and we're
going to have a look at that one again
to uh i'm sorry it forms a false part of
the list that we'll go on to in a second
um when we go into the more
semi-permanent uh semi-permanent areas
um the skill of the schemes that we
looked at were where edge lane marlin
road
and and uh and chester road between west
point and city road
we we're holding those in there holding
those in the bayonets because
more money make it may come along but
one of the things that we did want to do
with trench too
was to make it achievable the time
scales on these uh it can't be
overstated were very very quick and uh
and the
and the uh time scales for trance two
which i'll go into in a second in a
second
have actually moved but doing
fewer projects rather than lots and lots
of projects with the consultation
consultation times
is the only way that we'd actually we'd
actually make sure that we could
actually deliver deliver on the ground
another next slide please
so active travel schemes two tries to
there are three uh three schemes on the
tranche two
parts of it it's now to be uh now to be
delivered by march through
march 22. originally triatrons ii was
part of the emergency active travel
and had to be delivered by march 2021
so as you can see delivering uh
delivering the schemes from charge one
and the schemes from charge two
in what what effectively turned out to
be uh it turned out to be a seven to
eight uh to eight month period
was seen to be too much for uh for any
uh local authority and certainly
and certainly ourselves would have been
that would have been quite daunting um
we um we started to look at a longer
list as we said before
but we've come to we've come down to uh
to these three schemes which were
uh which we're going to look at in the
in the next period
so uh so to be fair we can now do a
longer period of consultation with these
than we did with
toronto also also learned some of the
lessons
of why some things didn't work and why
but why residents don't want
some of some of these uh some some of
the uh projects
in in tranche too with a with a bit of a
a bit of a uh a more acceptable kind of
time scale around it
um next
next likely sorry
in terms of consultation uh what we've
done a little bit of a disclaimer at the
top but
in terms of the a56 we're design
underway and consultation will start in
june
um this will be instead of making the
cones into
comes into into one some of those ones
will remain
but what will what we'll look at is some
of the pinch points pinch points in the
center
and the center of the uh of the area
areas around the uh around the stratfor
tip
that we we have to make sure that make
sure are
safe for safe for cyclists and uh and
the
on the road real public as well and uh
i'll make sure that we've um
make sure that we've actually got a
legacy going forward um
one of the things that we did want to do
on the a56 is make sure there is an
alternative
way of traveling from um stratford
uh right the way through in the white
way through to manchester so that it so
that effectively could become
a commuter room and uh and also provide
provide people away
of getting into the city centre on
weekends that uh that doesn't mean that
they have to use the car
um so in terms of those phase four
bridgewater lane
bridgewater road to edge lane
the talbot road to bridgewater road
northbound to the uh stratfor gyratory
and also in both directions on the
bridgewater expressway
which uh which is a little bit
incongruous on that road
um actually making it into somewhere
somewhere that people can cycle
next slide please
ed's lane will will be exactly the same
in terms of its um
in terms of uh the the consultation time
and the proposal there is to where to
make semi-permanent the uh
what we've what we've done um and it
just gives the uh gives the a56
a link towards the metrolink grammar
school longford park
and uh beyond into old trafford and uh
and furswood
and also joining up with uh with the
work that manchester city council have
done
on the uh on the other side of the
border uh going into uh going into chol
uh we'll also start consultation on the
oxford road and peter street
peter street model filters at uh
in march 21 so we'll try and accelerate
that as it's a smaller scheme
next slide please
to do that we've we've undertaken a bit
of a lessons learned we wanted to
understand because
because of the time scales involved it
was it was quite a um
quite a pressured environment if you
like through the through the period and
what we
what we wanted to do was to make sure
that make sure that when we when we came
through this to the selection of the
of these sites the specification of them
that could we
could we make them as holistic as
possible because i think we've learned
some lessons on lost i lost that road
for instance
around around the limitations of the
funding that limitations would only
allow us to put boards in
whereas actually the north side of
lostop deserved more than that
needed more than that to make it to make
it into it into a
a cycleway a cycleway that would stick
and
make sure our design is is right and our
design parameters around
making it usable for uh cyclists but
also making it usable for the
for the residents around it so that they
can they can navigate
uh navigate their lives around something
which is a change and it is a big change
for
uh for certain areas um because
most of our we automatically think by
car
and and realistically going forward
we've we've maybe got to change
an element an element of that view but
that does take some changing
um consultation and communication i
think is absolutely key
i think with the time scales we didn't
um um in
in some of the uh some of the areas the
consultation consultation could have
been better and i think that
communications got to
got to be sharper just to get people's
hearts and minds
behind actually what we're trying to do
with uh with these things and i think
that is something that we've
got to learn and in terms of the
implementation being able to uh being
able to react
to what people what people want in
particular areas
um but just some just some kind of good
statistics really
the a56 and the 300 uplifting people
cycling along it
during the period and we had a lot of um
a lot of feedback
saying that it was the right thing and
and longford park
we've got uh we've got a um a big
a big number of people who are enjoying
the fact that uh that that they
care that they uh uh can utilize that
utilize their roads and say in a safer
manner than their year than they were
before
we've got to bear in mind that there is
the other the the other percentage of
people who
who who don't like the change that uh
that's come in and that's and that we've
also got to bear in mind
and the idea though is that uh that with
the with the a56 and the
modal filters is that we do try and
encourage different types of transport
around the
around the borough uh in line with clean
air plant in line with
uh in line with our uh aspirations and
the and the climate change emergency
that we try and wean people off the cars
and realistically within a pandemic
where people
people aren't on traveling as much and
even even
as we as we sit here today and do this
meeting uh this meeting on zoom
then uh then realistically it's it's
trying to push
uh that that agenda in a in as um
uh as good a manner as we possibly can
next slide please
so in terms of the two questions that
were that were asked um
the uh the temporary schemes within
within toronto and all those implemented
are going to remain
and be monitored and we'll look at those
although we have to we have set a uh
uh a time limit on one foot on long for
park for another consultation
and the uh on the exception of the
northern side of lost road which we
which we have taken out um and in terms
of the
public engagement and consultation uh
consultation i think we've been through
that but also it's just to say that
we'll learn the lessons for trance too
that we learnt in tranche one and
implement those to uh
to allow a proper communication policy
so people learn so people can
can see comment and uh and actually
and actually review what's going to
happen outside their houses so
thanks jeff okay thanks very much
chris much appreciated for that
presentation
quite quite informative um
are there any questions
any questions from members
no no questions
ah right yes and uh councillor dr
barclay as well so council alum
right thank you very much uh chair and
uh thank you
chris for that uh presentation uh and
would totally endorse uh the point that
you know consultation
is is gonna be really important here
because as you say
uh and we've found the the schemes
can be quite divisive for communities
and
it's therefore you know really important
that
we spend as much time as is necessary
because you know these are turning into
fairly permanent
changes to our infrastructure so it's
important to get it
to get it right so i just wanted to ask
a couple of questions about
thinking about assessment uh
particularly
uh on routes like the a56 those you know
that are that
key arterial route in our borough do we
do
a sort of economic impact as well and
and what i'm thinking about there
maybe to state the obvious is that you
know
as we come out of the pandemic uh and
accept your point that maybe quite a
number of us will sort of do
zoom stuff and what have you but you
know we're bound to see a uh
uh you know an increase in that traffic
uh on
on the a56 do we have a think about
what you know those slower journey times
which seems to me
inevitable uh has on the economy i'm
thinking about
you know sort of business relocations
and that
sort of thing and then the other point i
just wanted to ask about was
uh you mentioned the city of manchester
other
boroughs will no doubt be doing the same
sort of thing and i'm thinking about
those other arterial
routes like the a6 in stockport and then
they'll be the ones you know sort of
radiating out from the city of
manchester um
presumably those boroughs have done
similar
sorts of things and i'm just wondering
to what extent we've been able to
get some learning done from you know
from a from a gm
point of view in terms of you know and
particularly with the arterial roots
which seem to be
uh to my mind you know potentially the
more problematic
fine um on the economic on the economic
part i'm
fairly sure richard richard will also
work will also come in on that one but
but from uh from our point of view um at
this moment in time what we what we've
tried to do is
with the tranche one and the and the a56
it was to react to the circumstance of
lesser traffic
so uh so i totally take the point that
so that traffic
probably will rise but uh but i think
there's i think there's
there's two um i think two points to to
kind of raise around them
and the the first one is that uh that in
terms of the
terms of uh the clean air plan and and
moving forward
we uh we are we are actually actively
trying to push people
out of carts from uh from into into the
uh
into the city the the slower journey
times
um around around the around the eighth
the a56
really only occurred in in two or three
pinch points actually
during the uh during the period even
when the even when the the cars came
back
and at one point at one point we were uh
there were two
major pinch punch which caused red
problems
i get a a report from uh from gm around
the uh around uh traffic on the a56 all
the way through our to
our trouble and the two which caused the
uh call from the issue were when we
extended to sale
and there was uh and the uh and
right turn issues became a problem
and uh through ghost hill from where we
uh where
the end of gorsle really where it hit
the white city roundabout
around there was it was an obvious pinch
point which we then shortened back so we
did review
around that to try and make sure that we
weren't having a derogatory or two
derogatory effects on the on the
uh on the on the time scales through the
piece
but even then the
the actual hit to uh to times to
times across the day was uh was between
35 and 50 seconds
um so although i could see your point
in terms of the economic the economic
impact it wasn't massive through
through through that through that
through that period of time
and even tftm were kind of surprised
actually i think a little bit around
around that uh that kind of uh that kind
of
downturn it wasn't it wasn't as it
wasn't as large i think
the sale where the sale part of it did
get out did happen there's no there's no
doubt about it and we reacted to it
and it was a yeah it was a a
particularly bad sunday but
as soon as we saw the saw the figures it
was not
it was not practical to uh to kind of
take it take it
uh further down um in terms of gm
uh the money for any of these projects
is
uh is basically our gatekeeper is uh
is tfgm with this so we work very very
closely with um
with the mayor's um cycling cycling team
and uh
under colleague of mine richard nixon
and um
and richard uh has a uh
has worked with stockport manchester
around uh around cycling cycling schemes
manchester took a slightly different
view that they uh they with with their
capital funding
were spending a lot of money on
permanent projects
so uh so the charlton charlton link that
we
talked about uh tying into a tying into
a long along edge lane
is uh is a good uh is a good example of
that
plus the um plus basically um
the um the elements are the elements
along charlton lane into
the to the main roundabout at white city
as well as the works that they're doing
underneath the
underneath the um the princess
the mancunian way but we uh
but what we what they didn't want to do
was to do
um temporary cycle routes because they
wanted to divert some of that money
into into actually the other side of it
which is protecting walking
around there around the city center and
i could totally get that
however what we uh what we uh um
being more of a linear borough if you
like it and and
a commuter realistically
uh the uh we we had to put our kind of
kind of focus on
where we could actually make a
difference and that uh and that for me
was
was making sure that we had a clear
route into manchester for those people
who wanted wanted to use it
we didn't have a dean's game so you know
into in terms of
in terms of that that particular bit
other boroughs wanted to do it
but we're we're kind of um we're kind of
very lucky
in in trafford that we have this
arterial route that's all ours
uh stockport wanted to do i think
something yeah something similar but
because because the the differing views
on different different councils
their their arterial route is shared
between more than one
and we're lucky to to actually have our
own uh have our own
um arterial route if you like that we
could do
sulfur did very similar things in terms
of uh in terms of
liverpool road that they that they they
took out
they didn't choose region rail but they
took the they said they had the parallel
route which they which they used which
was which i think was sensible
we don't really have that parallel route
the exception being the turf being
talbot road cycleway
and the the uh after the um
the drop in traffic um uh once the
ones lock down one was over then you
noticed that we dropped the gauss hill
section and moved to
move to use our existing cycle way on
tolbert road as being uh as being
basically the link
to to make sure that we used any
parallel route that we probably that we
possibly could
but the uh but the the intention as well
is to is to keep as much road space as
we can
and we don't want to cause one to cause
traffic jumps we don't we don't want to
cause uh cause any
deterioration to uh to the to the air
quality at all
but what we want to do is to make sure
that the the road space is shared
is shared and remain shared so uh so
that
there is space for people to walk space
for people to
um uh people to to ride their bikes and
also this where the space for
for uh for it still to be the arterial
arterial route
uh although if they can use the tram and
they can use the uh use the cycling
route and they can walk we'd much prefer
that
that's great chris david can i just come
up with a very brief
sort of question just on that it's
something that chris has said about the
uh delay in in journey time uh
measured in a number of seconds and i
was just wondering whether
does that therefore mean that there is a
sort of threshold
at which you know we would say actually
uh you know the impact is uh is
excessive here so we need to do
something
uh you know as opposed to yeah that's an
acceptable
delay therefore we're happy with the
scheme is there a is that a sort of
threshold is it is it measured in that
small number of seconds that you've just
mentioned
um it's never quite as simple as simple
as that because
because in terms of it i wish it was a
minute and thirty seconds says this exit
although it's not it's never quite
that's that simple i think yeah i think
we've um we've got a
um there is a sliding scale and also and
also it's an average
so uh so basically what might be what
might be perfectly acceptable
at 11 30 in the morning uh probably
isn't at five o'clock at
five o'clock in the evening and so we do
need to uh we do need to basically make
sure that
uh that we have a um uh
that basically across the piece we can
see
where those pinch points are as they
went down it comes down to an aggregated
aggregated amount which is what i quoted
with the with the seconds
but um but as i said before you could
quite clearly see where the
where the problems were and the problems
were around making sure that people
could turn right at gauss hill making
sure that there was an issue and the
the issue around uh around white city
and also when we did extend it for that
short period of time into sale
but there was obviously an issue and and
hopefully we reacted quick enough
to um to do it probably not for anybody
who was trapped in there trapped in
traffic that sunday afternoon
but uh but it was uh it was taken back
taken back on the monday to make sure
that we didn't
we didn't get in the way of of people's
journeys but also
also any any other traffic they use that
how long motorists have got the patience
to wait
30 seconds um you know
that if if it was down to that measure
of the patients i don't think it'd be
very long indeed
so uh over over to you richard
just just to add i think it seems time
can be a bit of a blunt
instrument if we if we're not careful
and i think it is important that we look
at it in the round
and also recognize um how traffic was
particularly down the air 56 towards the
town centre through stretford and gauss
hill
um in the pre-covered world if you drop
down there at the end of 2019 in the
beginning of 2020 when traffic was
very very slow and in my experience
a lot slower than it has been over the
last 11 months
and and also in terms of some of the
other council
priorities so things like the clean air
plan which chris has referred from the
climate change emergency and the carbon
neutral
framework and we know that vehicle uh
emissions are a significant
contributor to our carbon spend in the
borough
our regeneration proposals for stretford
and stratford town center and we know
that the a-56
is about as seen as a barrier within the
town between
those on either side of the air 56 and
thinking about how that
key arterial route can work in a
different way
to support uh the community bring the
communities together and support the
regeneration town centre
something that's very important to us
and so there's a really difficult
balance between lots of
things in in conflict and intention
there and i think that's some of that
that challenge which is what has played
out on a lot on a number of c schemes of
the
of the year so i think journey times
for cars is one part
of uh the metric that we need to look at
so
is journey time and for cycles and the
number of people who are cycling so is
air quality so it's carbon cost
and so it's economic impacts and looking
at the economic impact
there's a very traditional way of
looking that which is the time
lost by people spent in traffic jams and
that's that's
done often but i think we need to also
look at
how does how else can we measure that
are there different variable economic
impacts we don't necessarily look at the
impact on
uh journey times for pedestrians or on
charm users all the time that's lost
people looking for a space to park
so it's quite a complex picture
and so i think it's the right question
do we do we need to look at economic
impact but i think we need to consider
it
along across a range of other impacts
and against overall council priorities
in our corporate strategy
i think uh councillor rose thompson uh
in the chat around on the opposite side
cycling into manchester was quicker i
guess and
i suppose that's a point that you you
know you're all making
really um i need to bring in change
look it's coming quickly yeah yeah just
because i need to
yeah yes uh just very quickly i mean
obviously chris covered uh massively
extensively
say over the past summer and on the
autumn uh myself which krishna was
discussed uh all aspects safe
on a very regular basis we did look at
the information from transport for
greater manchester and we did look at
obviously we're getting feedback regular
from them and actually all these
problems there were a number of spots uh
where where there were problems
developing and they were and
they were dealt with very quickly as we
went along uh i think also
what what we are linking into is in the
longer term next few years
we're going to be developing the
stratford town centre strategy and that
will look further again at those areas
around stratford
but in addition to that as i was
commenting today to some reward members
around gorsle that there are a number of
things that linked into that with the
mayor's challenge fund work
actually how uh cyclists will access
particularly to
talbot road section of it and indeed uh
around the great stone road area
because one of the concerns was around
this is that uh that there was some uh
information being circled around and
said well why have you taken off course
hill
i think what what's been developed over
the years is working with the cycle
forum and other cycling groups
was to develop target load as a default
cycle area through that zone
and the idea was we get cyclists onto
talbot road and then gets
cars off target world back into chester
road so it's actually getting that feel
for that whole zone through there and
that was
uh part of thinking we're doing as well
in that center and measures are also
being looked at
uh then when you get down to white city
to filter them back onto the new
proposals as we've had to move on to
british waterway
for lincoln and poland so it hasn't just
been done in isolation we have been
taking account of all the aspects and
just to finish their quickly chair
so one of the things that that's [ __ ]
and it's being worked up it's a
comprehensive walking and cycling that
strategy which will be uh
it would it's been delayed a bit because
recent months but obviously
that will be coming out at some point
and it will be it circulated obviously
for
consultations or actually setting out
the whole strategy of what we've done
where we're going and everything about
that would be quite a comprehensive
document improving walking recycling
linking in all their strategies
but not just on our own but obviously
that'll be uh i was linking to it up and
running around over above us as well
that's hopefully that's uh is helpful on
that point chair thank you
thanks for that um i've got uh three
people in the
chat um counselor dr karen barkley
uh councillor john holden
and councillor rollers thompson although
i think
um councillor rose thompson i've just
mentioned
uh was a point really
so uh councillor dr karen barkley
thank you chairman and thank you chris
for your presentation i just got a
couple of questions
and first one is how are you actually
going to quantify
support or opposition is it on a
numerical basis how
how are you actually going to come to a
decision for the more um
contentious schemes that they actually
do have
either support or not support so i would
just be interested for that
and particularly when you say in
reference to oldfield lane
which is actually in my in my ward and
there has been quite a lot of opposition
perhaps it's not been registered
uh yes um in your actual figures but
both parish councils
warburton parish council and the massive
parish council
haven't supported that so i just wonder
first of all how are you going to
quantify
and whether something is actually
supported or not thank you
yeah i think the uh i think the the
easiest way
it has to be quantified uh quantified
numerically really
um and we know that's not well that's
never a that's never
completely perfect with uh with um
uh with taking people's views um i think
the uh i think we've
we've looked at a numerator a number of
different different methods around
around utilizing uh websites and uh and
so on but we also know that
not everybody uh not everybody has is uh
is it literate with it within that
so we're trying to do a mix of uh of
kind of approaches which do
gain uh do again kind of um
that we can quantify in terms in terms
of of numbers
um we've with old feeling all feeling
off and lane actually was uh was
was in terms of pure numbers despite the
parish council's concerns which were
taken into account
um in terms of pure numbers was uh was
was one of the most uh
one of the most um supported ones the
ones that we uh we took forward um it
were it had
numerous comments on our on the web
streaming which uh which what is one of
the things that we we take into account
we also took into account elements of uh
elements of uh
emails that uh that came into uh came
into it
uh and responses to the the handle of
the letters
that we did so uh so we've we've tried
to kind of
within the time scales that we're taking
i think i think that's one thing that
hopefully i got across within the within
the within the presentation that
to enable us to do anything we had to do
a uh we had to make
um uh make these decisions at pace
and to uh to enable us to to kind of
make those first steps
we had to find ways of finding ways of
getting from people
actually what they wanted and that was
where the uh where the
where the website web system actually
came into it came into its own
um but in terms of quantifying it is
around responses uh responses for the
for the delivered letters that we that
that we get we've given
it's around that uh round responses on
the on the website which is uh
um which is which was we publicized
quite extensively within
within trafford on both our website but
the old avoid the um
the one traffic partnership many of the
twitter feeds and through and through
very
any any and all kind of uh kind of bits
i think
that i think the tftm even carried even
carried some of the uh some of the
messages across
so we've tried to be as all encompassing
as we could
with the um proviso
that the time scales were very very
short to where to enable us to do this
with and just bring you back to to the
first to the first point of the
conversation
the to uh to the first point of one of
one of the bits on the presentation
there was only a period of three months
that uh that
that we could that we could uh that we
could actually move from
hearing about uh actually actually doing
it to
actually making sure that something was
actually in place so
that's ridiculously short time scales
for for
what we what we were trying to do but we
in the period of time that it was done
in the middle of the
in the middle of the um of the uh of the
the pandemic uh pandemic and people
wanting and actively showing that they
wanted to wanted to use different forms
of
forms of transport and then then
basically
the decisions were taken from taking on
numeric numerical basis from that
um and to be fair the old field lane one
has actually been
has actually been extensively used and
uh and to be fair
um i know for a certain and whenever i
talk about cycling that 100
of the people will not agree with me
that is one thing i have learned in the
last uh
in the in the last 10 months very very
definitively
but what i would say what i would say is
that uh within
within the oilfield lane part of it
certainly um it seems to have gone there
i've gone down really well with the
majority of people
okay thank you for that
counselor i haven't finished sorry sorry
uh chair i had a couple of things and
can i just follow it really really
quickly i'll be really quick
um justice thank you chair just to say
that um i do appreciate that oldfield
lane definitely had a lot of support
from the local residents
um but could have parish councils i
don't think i should have the chance to
respond so when you quantify the parish
councils
how what kind of weights given to them
because obviously they speak for
a large number of people and you know
basically
they've taken into account
so just yeah real quick question so what
weight would be given to a parish
council thank you
well in terms of in terms of it has a
numeric numeric value within that
to be honest to be honest it would uh we
we take on taking on our
um uh taking a view from uh from that
parish council
extremely seriously but in terms of a uh
instead of a numeric value
it will be it will be seen as being a
negative or a positive positive
positive within that we uh it's it's
very it will be very hard to quantity
quantify from uh from a british council
parish council basis uh what we'd
encourage people to do
to do via the parish council is is to
come individually as well because it
gives us a chance to actually uh to
actually count them
um we are it's not uh it's not kind of
saying that
we're definitely interested in what the
parish councils think without without
without a doubt they
they are uh they are one of our the uh
they are obviously
obviously very vociferous within that
within that particular area why not
um but actually we'd encourage we'd
encourage them to actually come to us
with the
with the amount of supporters or
non-supporters that they've actually got
because we've got to make some kind of
some kind of a
view on on this otherwise we
we would as i say be uh have been be
always trying to make a decision and
never actually make one
and uh i still think that uh still think
that within
within that particular particular area
the work that's been done down there
actually
actually has a has allowed a lot more
people to cycle and walk to a place to
where people where people want to go
and and realistically within that taking
the parish council views it views
into into account i think we make the
right decision okay thank you chad i
appreciate that thank you
thank you councillor john holden
thanks dave two
questions one slight plea for help
i saw in your presentation the
engagement tool
commonplace should i worry that i didn't
know that existed
especially as people who use the a56
probably live in my ward and the second
question 300 uplifting people
cycling on the a56
where because quite frankly
when i've used the a56 not infrequently
over the last few months seeing a
cyclist
has the same effect as watching a black
bear come out of the forest in the
national park
they've been so rare and i have seen
few if any people using those those
cycle routes where is that 300
uplift come from and who's using them
and when
okay and the uh in terms of in terms of
that i just caught the
uh called the other comment as well
in terms of in terms of uh the second
one uh the second one i'll take first
uh the 300 the um
we set up counters uh so uh so to be
fair
where they're coming from um they were
coming if there were local journeys but
there were also there were also quite a
few
uh quite a few journeys into uh into uh
into the city um within the week the
biggest uplift was on weekend
actually funnily enough so uh so the uh
so in terms of
in terms of commuter route um probably
not as used as
used as we would have liked but um but
there was a big
recreational use within the uh within
the uh within the weekend
um and i think some quite well
publicized uh published
kind of group rides actually used it
using it to get into uh to get into
manchester which was
which was nice to see um i think also
though
that is probably uh representative as
well
of of the of the fact that again we're
using this zoom and and i think i think
actually
commuters and that period of time going
into certainly in the summer
uh going into uh going into manchester
were limited when it came when
when it came to vehicular transport as
much as as much as cycling
but we did get a big uplift in uh
uplifting people people utilizing
utilizing it
for um for recreation moving into moving
into the uh into the city but also
in the week there was uh there were um
there were signs that uh that actually
uh that actually there were people
starting to move on it
bearing in mind that that um in the in
the summer as well unprecedented amounts
of
amounts of bicycles were actually were
actually sold in this country
um and certainly around the manchester
area lots of people
bought bikes and uh and started to start
to use them and
use them in in more and more um
in more and more situations but i don't
think it's probably the time to have
measured
measured commuting because i think i
think actually
we're naughty we weren't in a commuting
community in place
and i think by the time that people did
communicate commute it was probably into
the septembers october's november's
where
we do see a fall off in cycling for
obvious reasons unfortunately
our weather doesn't you know whether
it's not massively clement uh when it
comes to that period of time
um but the um the the old adage
of kind of build it on there will come i
think i think what we've got to do is to
make sure the balance
is is there between all three types of
uh types of transport
to uh to make sure that to make sure
that commuting by
bicycle and by you know and other forms
of transport you know the the amount of
investment that's gone into the
metrolink as well
to get people uh to get people to uh to
utilize those bits
is seen as being the future of transport
and we and we and we see that
see that we can that we can use
non-fossil fuels to uh
to get in there but you've you've got to
have the infrastructure in place for
people to uh to
to move that to move that behavior john
lambs
asked um what what does 300
represent in numbers i can get the
figures actually to to be felt the top
of my head i can
uh yeah i'm not uh i get i can't really
i can't remember it's a while it's
wow that's absolutely fine
no i can't i can get the uh get the last
few it's not
it's not ridiculous there were floods
going going in on it on
on mondays mondays tuesdays but as i say
it's about building something for the
future
unfortunately if if behavior if
behavioral change was uh
was that quick then uh then we'd be we'd
uh we'd succeed in a lot of things
a lot of things immediately wouldn't we
um i'm afraid it will take a little bit
longer than that last via us for the
first point
around commonplace um we did make it
available on the website we did make it
available on twitter we did we tried to
uh try to push
um all of the all of the youtube usual
um
uh media parts of it probably not aware
of commonplace because commonplace was
the back
platform so uh so basically you you
would
if you followed the link on on twitter
or you fold the link on the website for
instance you probably wouldn't clock the
fact that you were in a
commonplace website you were in
trafford's uh trafford
cycling and cycling bit um it is it is a
good platform
it allows for it allows on a map basis
for people to see
their area where they live and to and to
pull out
and comment on particular areas so for
instance i can go in if there is an area
outside
where i live that there's an issue with
i can
i can pinpoint it on the map and i can
place a comment that we can then collate
in an orderly fashion
and what we tried to do within that was
to look that where there was a build up
of
uh build up of comments where individual
comments were
and there was something meaningful we we
definitely did have it did have a look
at it that's not to say that but where
you got
um kind of 15 16 17 comments in one
particular place
then that that must show that there is
that there is something there to be
looked at
from a uh from a point of view of is
there something we can change in that
particular area
and that's that's all the commonplace
website was there today
okay well thanks very much chris and you
know can i just say
david thank you chris that's actually
cleared up a lot of
irritating points that i i'd come up
with when i was writing my notes this
morning
and i feel now i can actually make a
case to some of my residents
who might not see the uh the value
and i would say that i'm getting used to
the a56 and
the cycle lane and i actually haven't
got close to killing anybody yet
so perhaps it's going to work i'm i'm
very relieved to hear that
thank you aren't we all yeah but yeah
can i thank you chris uh
and richard and steve uh it's very
helpful
and i'm sure that we will uh come back
to this
as we progress and i think what um
what the council is trying to do is to
get people
you know out of their cars we we do have
a
um you know a climate emergency and i
think we need to
uh you know try and change people's
minds as much as we possibly can
but we have to do it in such a way that
uh
you know people become accepted uh
of of it and uh it's not just
shut straight up and i think as john
mama's
said you know consultation is absolutely
crucial
in relation to that and i know that
you haven't had a great deal of time for
the consultation
because of the pressure that was put on
to us
um in relation to a lot of these schemes
particularly
earlier on but i think um you know
when the pandemic has long gone uh
hopefully in the not too distant
future then you know i just hope that we
don't
forget this and that we continue to make
the progress
that we are making uh because i think it
will be better for
everyone in the future uh in the long
run
so thanks very much for all the work
that you do and it's
been much appreciated and i'm sure that
we'll be inviting you
again in the not too distant future uh
to
to give us some updates so thanks thanks
a lot
okay um we can now move on to
uh item six with which is the
economic uh recovery plan and for this
i think we've got richard rowe
and i believe her hadrian uh fisher
and we've got um yeah
and we've got councillor mike freeman
who is the executive member
so mike do you want to just and just
thank you thank you sir just very brief
to say that we're going to have a
presentation tonight from
adrian fisher who's our director of
growth and regulatory services
on the economy economy recovery plan
and that's been prepared to identify the
specific actions required to ensure
effective economic recovery and the
delivery of a more inclusive economy in
traffic
as we come out of this pandemic um and
um there will be chair a paper beam
is being prepared to go forward to the
executive meeting
on the 22nd um of february and with that
i'll
pass over to adrian if i may for the
presentation
thank you thank you very much all right
thank you thank you council free member
thank you chair um good evening
everybody i'm i'm adrian fisher i'm
director of growth and regulatory
services so
i will now try and share my screen and
hope
that it works this time so if you bear
with me
um
right i do apologize uh we seem to be
having technical difficulties
today i don't know whether um
under murray is able to um step into the
breach
alex
i'll put it over a second just one
second
there we are that's great thank you and
i think you can go to
full screen mode if that will work but
uh there we are
lovely okay so um uh as i say this is uh
just really to introduce the uh the
matter of the economic recovery plan
as council freeman said um there will be
a fuller report
that will be going to uh the forthcoming
executive
uh meeting but um this will give a
hopefully a flavor
of of what we've been working on and
some of the you know the key issues
really
uh that we've been examining when it
comes to recovering so
next slide please i think
i mean the first thing to stress really
is that uh
this economic plan uh does not exist in
isolation and
and it's really part of um a
comprehensive
look at covid recovery and there are
a series of themes a number of which you
can see there
along the bottom of the slide and
collectively
you know they form part of a whole
governance arrangement
um around kovid recovery that then links
back to
the executive uh and indeed this
committee and also
um the trafford partnership so um just
simply to say some stress
that uh this is intended to complement
uh
other measures that the council is
carrying out
next slide please
the other point perhaps by to say by way
of introduction
is that um when we're thinking about
recovery of course
uh you know there's a huge amount of
national effort uh in this area
um and you know the government will has
got a number of initiatives already
underway it has
other things in the pipeline so um
what we're looking at essentially is how
uh the pandemic
um applies to the trafford economy so
we're trying to make this
local and specific not seeking to
replicate
uh what's being done at the national
level um but very much
apply it uh to our own borough but
bearing in mind also that
um when still you know in the thick of
things we cannot really be sure of all
of those impacts
so um to some extent there has to be a
degree of flexibility around this
um and um you know to that extent we're
probably
trying to address this with a range of
measures as well
in addition to that it's important to
note that you know the pandemic
does not arrive you know completely in a
vacuum
it came to us in the world that we
inhabited at the start of of 2020 and
then of course
you know there were lots of existing
economic and and other
societal trends that we were grappling
with at that point
long before we'd we'd we'd heard of
kovic 19
and so when we emerge you know many of
those are still going to be there so
so the illustration is is of uh you know
a boarded up pub and and if you think
about the
some of the changes in the hospitality
industry um you know there's been a
trend
for pub closures that's been going on
for several years now sadly that might
be exacerbated by the pandemic but
nevertheless you know that's something
that's been with us and you can think
about impacts on high street and
internet shopping and those sorts of
things so
you know we are we're not coming to this
cold and as we emerge
some of those trends and issues that we
were very bothered about
uh back in the beginning of 2020 will
also come to the fall so we have
to uh think about these plans uh in the
world
that we already find ourselves in next
slide please
so really um what this economic recovery
plan does
is is look at a series of themes so
roughly nine in all
where we're we're trying to see where we
can have an impact and have an influence
uh in terms of of economic recovery in
our locality
and the first one of those i think is
really important is about support
uh for businesses and support for
uh job creation and a lot of that is
really helping
businesses emerge to deal with keep on
working
you know through current lockdowns
through through current
uh difficult conditions which perhaps
are still going to be with us
um for some months we know that there
are certain sectors
that are going to be perhaps more
affected than others
uh and so to perhaps target those and to
look at
um you know changes in terms of you know
startup businesses self-employed
um the opportunity um that will come
from
you know a a churn in in the workforce
and and with that in mind um you know
grow support through um you know the
voluntary sector
through um you know community-based
organizations and
um that of course will also align with
um our principles in in the council's
equality strategy
so really a a very much a theme around
supporting
helping businesses uh helping people um
uh in to to grow employment at a local
level
next slide please
second point really is then around uh
again it's
it's a world as we find ourselves point
and that's as we recover
from uh kovid we will also be adjusting
to a significant change
uh in our trading relationships so
you know in as of the start of this year
um the previous trading links with the
eu
will have been replaced um with that of
course comes
certain constraints but also
opportunities so
it's really important that we frame the
recovery in that context of getting to
grips with that that new reality those
those new
trading positions and we can commission
um work to better understand that um
and also just look for where you know
both the impacts are but also where uh
businesses can
can adjust to take advantage of brexit
as well
next slide please
and another big theme of course that we
were all
concerned with and we've just been
discussing is is that of um carbon
reduction
and mitigating the impact of of climate
change
and so as we uh recover um
and we think about uh economic change
and economic recovery
uh there's a tremendous opportunity to
capitalize on some of the changes that
perhaps
we would be wanting to make in any event
and
um you know you can think about how
people have adjusted
very very rapidly to uh of necessity
to to the emergency of of covid
um and perhaps that gives us heart to
think that actually some of the changes
that we might have thought
very difficult or very slow might be
able to happen
rather quickly um than might have been
imagined so certainly there's a lot of
work to be done
um to support green business
uh green jobs and we have our our
carbon reduction plan and climate action
change
plan that was reported to the executive
a few months ago and an opportunity to
tie in that
when we're thinking about how we recover
next slide please
now really key part of um thinking about
recovery
is the impact on our communities
um and we know that
there will be certain sectors that will
be particularly
adversely affected um almost every day
we hear in the news
about analysis about the impact on
education
um so there is a real task here about um
skills uh and um making sure that people
have
access to the right support the right
education
um and you know there may be people that
will have to be
undergo retraining because the sectors
that they worked in previously
will have been damaged and and you know
they will have to think about
um new acquiring new skills so
i really important theme is is how we
can
ensure that all of our population all of
our communities but
perhaps especially young people have
access to
uh the skills and the opportunities they
need um
and here there's a really good tie-in uh
of course also with
um the trafford uh poverty strategy
uh and the way that you know we can make
sure that um there aren't going to be uh
communities uh left behind as the
economy starts to pick up
next slide please
now obviously it's one thing having um
uh
people with with the right skills and
writer
uh um aptitude uh for employment
um but none of that will be able to come
to fruition if we haven't got
uh the jobs uh available for people uh
locally and so uh another um
big theme is around uh securing inward
investment
and making sure that we have those jobs
that
uh will bring prosperity to to trafford
um and so it's always been a big
part of our regeneration and our
strategic growth team
um but that needs to continue to be part
of
the offer that we have to making uh
trafford you know a good and a
sustainable place
for business to grow employment and to
grow prosperity through that
next slide please
and one of the ways of course that we
can we can seek to do that
is being ready for funding opportunities
um so whilst perhaps overall the country
will be
facing some challenges uh financially in
the coming years
um i think it's also very likely that
there will be
um you know new initiatives there will
be perhaps investment in infrastructure
and then and in certain sectors and
we're already starting to see that
as we want to sort of stimulate the
government wants to stimulate growth so
um one thing that we can do locally
is making sure we're ready for that so
if in other words initiative comes along
we want to make sure that uh people in
trafford
and we as a council are ready for that
and that we can access
some of this funding uh to the benefit
of our residents
and businesses so being sort of
uh ready and and um watching out for
opportunities uh and new funds uh very
much something
we would look to do next slide please
and then um another area where perhaps
we have
um uh in some cases a particular
ability to influence um things is in
terms of our
our local environment i mean the
approach that we take
at a spatial level if you like to
different neighborhoods so
trafford park has been you know for many
many decades
um an essential part of our local
economy
um but um it has in a sense almost
reinvented itself
you know since it was first conceived uh
um
you know many many years ago so we need
to look after traffic park make sure
that it is ready
it's able to uh be part of that recovery
and will continue to be
a strong business location for the
future
now allied to that of course we have
trafford city and
um uh you know there are some big
developments uh uh coming
along which again we need to make sure
um come to fruition so we have a huge
investment
with the spa at thermae and also
very significant developments of
trafford waters with housing and
employment and all of that will
sort of complement the trafford park
trafford city offer
however there are plenty of other
locations where
investment in new development
and new development which of course will
sustain jobs um
both either of itself through the
construction phase
or also through the creation of new
workspace so we have
carrington of regeneration of passington
links through there into sail west
um and so a very significant
area of new development um
but that's not alone we have also um all
kind of regeneration
uh areas within the urban framework so
um highlight the civic quarter and
um stratford and these are places where
the council itself has
often land holdings we have our joint
ventures
we can steer those towards
spearheading that economic recovery so
we can play perhaps a more direct role
uh as as a as a funder as a landowner
in in some of these uh regeneration
locations
next slide please
the other area of course where the
council is particularly active
is within um town centres and
i think we'll all recognize that um town
centres have been
hit very hard and just as uh retailing
uh with perhaps declining and um we
might have thought that perhaps
hospitality
was uh one of the the areas where which
would
sort of come to the rescue of town
centres and of course
through the pandemic that's the sector
that's been uh particularly badly hit
so certainly town air town centers needs
to be
a huge area of focus um and that can
come through
town center marketing uh town center
development sites
um and and thinking about you know how
we can support
uh town center businesses overall
and next slide please
and then really i think that the final
area to highlight
is around the visitor economy um and i
suppose
this is recognizing that that everybody
has been um
spending an awful lot of time um uh
cooped up
uh in the four walls of their home um
everybody is anticipating that there
will be a tremendous appetite
um for getting out and about uh for
doing the things that people used to
enjoy
um and it's making sure that we're well
placed uh to capitalize on that
um so we know we have some you know
amazing venues within the borough
um we have the traffic city attractions
that's already mentioned
you know donna massey you know lots of
things
that will give um an opportunity
for a a great day out and and with that
of course
uh that brings jobs prosperity um
into the borough alongside it so the
visitor economy
um very much capitalizing on that
opportunity once we do
emerge from the pandemic uh so chair
that's really a flavor
of um the recovery plan and the key
themes within it
as i mentioned at the beginning we will
be um
there will be a full report um to a
forthcoming executive meeting
um but i mean hope in the meantime that
uh gives a sense
of the area that we're working on um and
uh you know how
that plan is shaping up so happy to take
uh questions thank you very much
i think that was a very helpful
presentation
and although there's not that many
slides i think there is a lot
in there that um you know uh
steers us in a way that we we can
recover in
trafford and i think we're all very keen
to ensure that we
recover quickly and effectively
and so um we've got questions
um councillor john holden and councillor
aidan williams the first ones councillor
john holden
thank you david
adrian can i just raise two points
one is about promoting adult education
and training absolutely no question that
that process
is going to be key to recovery not just
locally but nationally
i couldn't think of what levers we
have as a council that we can pull
to actually enhance the situation for
adult education and training
and the other question that i had was
about
the wider regeneration
of partington carrington and an area
close to my heart
sail west southwest is 100
residential and
i certainly not heard of any ideas that
are going to
change that so what do we mean
by the wider regeneration of sail west
thank you right
okay thank you shall i uh take those now
yeah yeah
okay um no thank you counselor um yeah
so perhaps i'll just
start with that latter question um uh
when we are talking about regeneration
um in particular in the context of sail
west
um it is part of that is is
is just in terms of the fabric and and
and the facilities
locally but it's also about
accessibility
and there is actually a quite a good
tie-in with what we've just been
discussing because
one of the the difficulties in in that
locality but also i think in partington
is that i mean these places are you know
as the crow flies not very far away from
some tremendous job opportunities but
the difficulties often that people
struggle to to access them
and that might be because public
transport is poor just access
generally is difficult but also you know
if you consider that a bicycle is is a
is a very
low cost means of of traveling say you
know two or three miles
um then that can be make a huge
difference to to somebody who is
is looking to to get into work so
certainly
that perhaps particularly is one of the
uh
aspects of cell west but more broadly um
as part of the the sort of
bigger new carrington um proposal there
is
a huge amount of new employment land
uh that will be coming on stream and
this is all on the former what was
previously the shell refinery um
and that will you know create many many
hectares
of new employment space you can see some
of that coming out of the ground
already and i suppose what we need to do
is
ensure that local people are able to
take advantage of those jobs some of
that is through
accessibility some of it can be through
things like local labor agreements
but it is also um through having right
skills and i think that then
breathes across your first question
around adult education
um and we do have already a program
uh uh uh along these lines um
uh and maybe that something we need to
sort of bring back in
in more detail potentially um but lots
of of things whereby for example
we're able to provide um the right
equipment so tablets and so on for
people to learn
language skills for those people for
whom english isn't the first
language you know really trying to
overcome
some of the barriers uh and ensure that
people um
you know we have a comprehensive
training plan um and certainly i can
probably
provide more detail to you of of that
program if that would be of assistance
yeah i think that would be helpful uh
adrian
okay john thank you
right count councillor aidan williams
uh thanks chad i i don't intend to speak
at great length you know i i don't have
any really
um sagely forensic questions to
to log around i just i thought i'd share
some thoughts that struck me during um
that presentation i think
one of the things that struck me is that
you know this is still an evolving
picture
i think much of the economic damage from
um the lockdown restrictions probably
won't be clear right now and
most likely won't become clearer until
quite a bit later in the year
um you know i say that with the
understanding that fellow is not even
wrapped up yet and i've been watching
that universal claimant tracker on the
weekly briefing that we receive um
from the council um and as i understand
it
the universal credit claiming rate in
traffic now is now more than double
what it was pre-covered um
so i i think i suppose you know that
there's a huge amount of damage that
we've yet to see is i suppose what i'm
trying to say though
and look i i was really pleased to see
the um adrian
and the presentation referred to a
commitment around youth employment in
particular
i mean i have what we do that
essentially the well-being and future
prospects of an entire generation of
young people have sort of been
um second thought during the course of
the last year
and certainly that's something that
plays on my mind whenever i think about
um
what the country's going to look like
over the course of the next 10
20 years um adrian touched in his
presentation on
um vcse and the role of the voluntary
sector
uh playing and the role that they can
play in the recovery
um i think effective recovery is really
going to require
um intelligent and proactive
collaborative working with a whole range
of partners and i think that's one thing
that's really being
um perhaps um
[Music]
a welcome lesson from the pandemic i
suppose it
is that we've seen in the community hubs
that there is still
very much a willingness and a sort of
enthusiasm
for community groups for different
businesses for different organizations
to work
with each other um you know we saw that
with the hubs as i've said but we also
saw it the other night in gauss hill
with tht stepping up to the plate in
terms of the evacuation of residents
when the police were executing those
warrants
and interestingly um
the booklet st martin's ward council has
had a conversation
um with orwell valley housing trust
housing association
last week uh possibly the week before
about their ambitions
um for sale west but also for um
sale more generally um
as they uh roll out the rest of the
estate regeneration package and i think
what what struck me is that they have a
huge amount that they can bring to the
table
and perhaps at times that that sort of
potential hasn't been fully tucked into
um and i do wonder whether or not
um the council's approach to partnership
working
then is something that perhaps scrutiny
committee can look at
um in greater detail moving forward
because i know council of wittens talks
about
um perhaps uh not restructuring but
reorganizing the way the partnership
working is executed
uh in in trafford and i think it would
be really interesting to see
whether or not there is possibility to
work more effectively with other
organizations and other um community
groups
as we as we do look to try and recover
from all that
yeah i'm just i i suppose just um
responding to what counselor
williams has said um certainly
um partnerships is probably perhaps you
might say almost like the golden thread
that
that would run through all of those
themes that
i referenced in the presentation um and
um perhaps just one
example of how perhaps as an authority
we can start to tackle that
is just in terms of our own internal
structures we are
intending to link the what might be
called a traditional
economic development team with our
community and partnerships team and that
is because
we recognize that um we you know there
is that tremendous untapped potential
and if we are to be effective and
thorough
about um some of these measures we have
to have those links through
into the whole community so working with
business but
working with voluntary sector working
with organizations like thd have you
know
huge um stock in our area as do overall
valley and many of the other housing
providers so
that sort of um ethos of partnership
certainly is one
that we are you know going up will be a
big feature of this recovery
for sure yeah if i could just come in
as well if that was okay um
just to pick up on a couple of uh
council willian's comments and i think
he's absolutely right
that um at this point in time we can't
fully work through what the economic
impact of corvid is
is going to be it's far too early and
in the cycle we're not through this
lockdown yet we don't know what the
future we don't know when exactly when
it's going to be lifted
as you said we don't know what happens
post furlough so we were very concerned
back in
october i think it was when we're
looking at furlough was going to end
it's obviously been extended but but we
are pushing back
an employment challenge undoubtedly um
and we don't know the impact of
brexit as yet and there's a lot of
implications still of that
to work through so there's an awful lot
of challenge
um there i think the other thing on the
counter to that is
that the economic recovery plan needs to
be seen
in the context of a wider recovery
strategy and so we've presented here the
economic recovery plan
almost as if it's a standalone document
but as adrian set out at the start of
this presentation
it is part of a much broader piece of
work looking at recovery across the
piece
partnerships is absolutely really
central part of that and now we engage
with the
volunteering community sector that's
something that we're putting a lot of
work into but also it's some of the work
that we're doing with colleagues in the
ccg and the wider determinants of health
because we know that there's a very
strong
relationship between economic
uh deprivation and uh and physical and
mental health
and you need to you need to tackle that
from both sides you can't just you can't
just
look at one element of that we also know
there's a very
strong um link uh between for example
things like obesity
and the impact that kobe does so there
are lots of things there
um so this will be i think a little bit
presented in a
slightly different way and the report
that
council of freedom reference that's
coming through to the executive at the
end of this month
where we will be presenting an update on
our broader recovery strategy
as well as then the economic recovery
plan element
of that that so hopefully you can then
start to see how
all those uh bits uh fit together um
and all the partnerships that makes back
to the vcsc
again i said really important piece of
work we would really welcome scrutiny's
input
into that um i would just uh ask as
uh adrian said there's there's a lot of
work that we're
carrying out at the moment around our
structures and around those reviews
it might be helpful if we were just some
of that could settle down i think maybe
before we came back to
scrutiny really happy to have that
conversation but if we could have it at
a point where i think it's just
developed a bit
more then that might be helpful we can
come back with something that's more
forward-looking rather than um
backward-looking if that will be okay
and more than happy to have a
conversation
offline about the timing and the scope
of that if that will be helpful
yeah okay thanks for that
but just on that theme um around
partnerships
uh i mean in my ward
a large part of trafford park hidden
gals hill and uh obviously
you know it it is a cent center of
development really and job opportunities
um
for for the region not not just uh
trafford and
um and it kind of
seems to look after itself to some
degree
and i i i think we we really do i know
years ago it had a traffic park
development corporation
which really um helped to
incentivize you know the companies that
were there and develop and but
you know and be supported
um but by you know the whole region
really
and and i just wonder
how we can actually tap into that and
develop a partnership
around you know trafford park
because we don't always get the benefits
of those
companies that do come in how we do that
i don't know but i think it's something
that we
we we need to look at
carefully and to see if we can develop
some
kind of partnership that then can drive
initiatives forward in terms of job
creation and training
and all the all the other things that we
want
um so
i've got a few more questions so i just
want you to keep that in mind for for
for the future really um i've got
um mike freeman wants to come in but
i'll bring
rose councillor rose thompson in first
she's got a question and i think
uh if if mike can come in
after that okay rose do you want to
question it's just an observation
really that's um the voluntary i work in
the volunteering community sector
in trafford and have done for 20 years
and
it's kind of bandied about so it's this
big
army of volunteers and networks and
groups that can come into action
at any time and i think the reality is
it isn't like that in trafford this um
there was a groundswell of volunteers
that came to the response hubs
at the beginning of last year but
they've now
drifted away and i do worry that
the volunteering community sector is
kind of misrepresented
and um people just put it in there as a
as an added resource that might not
actually be
the resource you think it is so it was
just an observation really
yeah it's not a bad point that you make
[Music]
yeah so that's an observation can i just
bring
in uh councilman mike freeman now
because he
he's taking the lead on the executive in
relation to
to this thanks chair i just want to
back up what uh richard rowe has had to
say really until it is
this is one piece of work the economic
recovery plan and and you'll see
as we develop there's a this it's
part of the overall recovery strategy
and it's one part of it
um and um so really the work i'm
involved in just cuts across an awful
lot of portfolios
and it probably might confuse one or two
counselors but
there is madness in in all in
what it's not madness but that there is
a way well
a reason why we're doing this is to have
an overall view that
one exact member can focus on what
exactly needs to be done
and i do work closely i want you all to
know with with my other
exec members in whose portfolios i
clearly do crossover
in this sort of work um i want to come
back on the council holding what you
were saying about
um our levers for promoting our
education and supporting local residents
of course you know one of the things we
were keen to do is is to look for
funding through the
um adult education budget local
authority grant
uh and we can deliver themes alleviating
barriers such as
digital inclusion digital connectivity
uh english is a second language
so that is being taken into into account
as part of the economic economy recovery
plan
and of course in march well very shortly
we do embark on a lending scheme from
libraries
for digital tablets computers etc which
we've worked hard to to get going um and
secondly uh on council williams you said
you were pleased about our uh
traffic pledge youth employment task
force we're very keen as well to ensure
by working with our chapel education
employment agencies that
that also includes disabled residents
and those with learning disabilities
seeking the same employment
opportunities
as able-bodied and and that's got to be
part that so that makes us
a truly inclusive uh econo economy
recovery plan
thanks chair okay and there's no
there's no other questions now okay
can i thank um you know
hey adrian and richard and mike
um i think it's been very helpful to
have this presentation uh it is it will
be a key factor
as we uh come out of the pandemic
and uh and it's something that scrutiny
really wants to
be a part of really and to try to
help develop you know the the uh
the plan uh and uh because obviously
will change um as we move
uh you know into the future uh
and i think you know the the the economy
in trafford we will benefit if we all
work together in relation to this and uh
and obviously we'll be
uh hoping to invite you uh
you know uh very much in in
in in that future uh and the meetings
that we have so that
thanks very much for for your commitment
and uh
and for the presentation and the work
that you do
with your blessed share may i now leave
the meeting
yes well i know that you wanted to watch
the match and uh
and a few others do as well
so i want to uh you know move on with
the agenda
thank you okay cheers
and thanks very much uh we'll now move
on to
uh item seven
um and this is the replacement uh
cladding in
uh the old old trafford uh high-rise and
um we we did receive a an update
um email from tht which uh
we we have circulated and and
really it's for noting for now but
you know the final uh what it says
basically is the final works to remove
the
acm cladding at the um
five old trafford tower blocks in
december that that that's now
um been being completed um
and phase two has started which is to
renew cladding uh with obviously
um new new material
and associated system works which has
now started at princess court
tht expect they will complete the works
by the autumn of
this year um
i think what what i i said earlier on
when we
when we talked about the question that
was asked by mr stevenson
um we we will uh clearly
uh put this on the agenda for the next
meeting
and uh tht will be invited and we'll
go through those questions and the
answers to the questions
at that particular time are we okay to
um to agree that
yeah and so
the next item is urgent business and i
don't have any and i think that
concludes the meeting and so
uh can i thank you all very much
uh much appreciated all the officers who
who've
you know spent a long time with us
tonight and
given the presentations and of course
our
our scrutiny officers as well and all
the members for
your contribution and and have a
safe journey into the tv room where you
can watch united
so bye to you all